hey guys merry here with a gamespot news
update it looks like the pc version of
batman arkham knight is showing some
serious bugs and glitches especially for
those using AMD graphics cards and the
ratings on Steam product page are
starting to reflect this the technical
issues on the pc version includes
sporadic freezes framerate stutters and
audio glitches some players had expected
issues after Warner Bros interactive
entertainment adjusted its system
requirements leaving it with a warning
about AMD compatibility problems
developer Rocksteady has released a
statement we're aware that some users
are reporting performance issues with a
pc version of batman arkham knight this
is something that Rocksteady takes very
seriously we're working closely with our
external PC development partner to make
sure these issues get resolved as
quickly as possible a mass of
disappointed customers have begun to
criticize the game on its steam user
page at the time of going to press
seventy percent of customers have not
recommended the title with some 2,000
customers pending negative reviews still
plan on purchasing batman arkham knight
or are you going to protest with your
wallet let me know in the comments below
for the latest on batman arkham knight
be sure to head to gamespot com / news
you